the winning agenda for every republican
is simple it would include making
america energy independent as it was
under donald trump again restoring law
and order in every town and every city
peace through strength abroad the
biggest meanest toughest badass military
on the face of the earth free and fair
trade draining the swamp election
integrity parental choice uh and control
and education cutting regulations
lowering taxes securing our border and
let's not forget the protection of your
natural rights god-given rights
constitutional rights and freedoms which
is something that gavin newsom seems to
know nothing about here with more author
of the number one new york times
bestseller here's the deal former senior
counselor to president trump kellyanne
conway okay am i wrong is he going to be
the new anointed one
i would bet a lot of money that i am
correct
sean i sure hope so
i mean the only difference really
between joe biden and gavin newsom is
that newsome can do a full 30 minutes on
the peloton bike you're talking about
shuffle border versus surf border but
the policies are the same
they're both socialist they both don't
like dealing with kamala harris
and i think the age difference is
irrelevant when you talk about the
policy similarities everything woke joe
biden is trying to do in washington dc
with one party democratic rule gavin
newsom either has tried to do or has
succeeded in doing
in woke one party democratic rule
in california but what is his greatest
export he's against oil and gas he's
against fracking in california
newsome of course opened hollywood
before he opened your children's schools
in california you pointed out quite
cogently all of the hypocrisy and the
hubris
that has marked his career and by the
way sean people should know all across
this country gavin newsom's elected
career started in 2004.
here's a guy who's been in public office
taxpayers you've been funding for
everything you see that he has
for 18 years and now he's going to run
for president i also think this is a bit
of a slap at kamala harris it was the
highest ranking californian in the
country in the federal government
obviously and it's a little bit of a
slap at andrew cuomo because he was sort
of the it governor
of new york until he resigned in
disgrace so now you have gavin newsom
what i think is fascinating sean
is
the ad that gavin newsom is running in
texas he literally starts out with
our creator
gave us life
i'm sure there are a lot of people out
there in california and otherwise in the
anti-religion democratic party saying
what's all this god talk dude and then
he's talking about gave us life and then
he does some
some sort of snarky and barky stuff
against governor abbott but notice how
gavin newsom does not yet have the
courage to go and run these ads in
so-called blue states with democratic
governors
like michigan or wisconsin or
pennsylvania i don't think they're blue
states i think they're purple states but
they do all have democratic governors
he's trying to raise his profile and
raise some money and raise a lot of
hackles
off the backs of successful republican
governors like texas kellyanne craig
as far as ron desantis
who else do they have oh
think about it
it's not mayor pete it's not kamala it's
not joe so there are the top three who
will they turn to
i'm predicting tonight they'll turn to
him um do you think well he's going to
be one of them
what
i think the odds are the odds are right
that gavin newsom will be in the mix
because he will say i'm a chief
executive i'm a governor i haven't been
part of the dysfunctional washington
swamp with one party rule where
absolutely nothing got done but here's
the difference
i think he's a governor when you're a
governor sean when you're a chief
executive you have to own and eat all of
your policies whether you're abiding in
washington or new sim in california in
sacramento if you're a senator like an
amy klobuchar who's going to come off as
minnesota nice who's going to be a woman
who can actually speak well
the kamala harris cannot who's not
damaged goods like elizabeth warren or
hillary clinton
okay
you can probably say i tried
well put down a marker you say it might
not be him i i say the odds are he's the
heavy favorite right now but time will
tell kellyanne congrats by the way i
think that's great let's run against him
thank you i'm fine with it i'm not a
doesn't worry me one bit if america
wants gavin newsom then america wants
failure because that's what california
has done it's failed hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else